[Music]
hi my name is emmy eaton my favorite
thing to do in
my hometown idaho
is i like potatoes and then eat them
there are more than a million potatoes
made each day yummy yummy yummy except i
don't like it when they're all dirty we
walked into the room where there were a
bunch of potatoes and there was like a
conveyor belt that was holding up like
the potatoes it shot water everywhere in
there and then we got to the big stack
of potatoes they have to wait one year
in the big like room they have to keep
it nice and cool so like there's fans
everywhere
and stuff because they don't want it to
go rotten and moldy
because that's gross
hi drew my name is simone and i am in my
hometown of baltimore maryland i love
baltimore because it has so much history
so much beauty but the thing i love most
here is the food scene i'm a food
vlogger here in the area so i post all
the best eats and drinks in baltimore so
i want to show you around
to some of baltimore's most fun and
exciting and delicious foodie
destination
first stop is belvedere square market
say hello to my friends at neopaul
savory smokery in general they sell all
kinds of smoked goods but neil paul
sells my favorite sandwich in baltimore
they're salmon blt and their famous new
zealand smoked mussels these are a must
try here in baltimore
last stop at belvedere square market is
tasha flowers i come to tasha to get my
bouquets for my living room kitchen
bedroom for the week so we're going to
grab this asiatic lily here because look
at that if it is perfectly open that's
just a little peek of belvedere square
market
now moving on to our second stop welcome
to chat hour at good neighbor coffee
shop
we'll have some very creative appetizers
great conversation
well drew that's just a small look at my
beautiful city of baltimore i hope you
loved it as much as i do and i hope to
see you here soon bye
hey drew it's sam i'm a halloween
lifestyle vlogger known online as
halloween happy i'm in my apartment here
in salem massachusetts and i am so
thrilled to show you around i love salem
so much because there's a lot of history
there's always something to do and see
and it has a halloween vibe all year
round which clearly you can tell i'm
obsessed with so grab your broom and
hang on tight and let me show you around
my hometown of salem massachusetts
we are at modern milly which is one of
my favorite shops i love coming here
because they're so nice and they always
make me feel so comfortable in my skin
when i'm trying new things with my style
i see that they have a few halloween
outfits so let's go check it out this is
tiffany
hello hi thank you so much for inviting
us in tell us a little bit about the
shop
we are an inclusive women-owned shop in
downtown salem we sell reproduction
vintage inspired clothing from sizes
extra small right on up to 6x and we're
happy to help style anybody when they
come in
thank you so much for showing us around
modern amelia all right guys on to the
next spot let's go
all right drew so i'm a crafter at heart
which leads me to our last stop here in
salem and that is the witchery so let's
go inside and talk with the owner gret
so what do you offer here so the
witchery is a creative space and we
offer book binding workshops and we
offer broom making workshops and behind
here you can see some of the brooms that
we make
we let people choose their own materials
to create a custom room
so if you do visit salem definitely
check out the witchery that way you can
make a craft take it home with you and
it's like you're taking a little piece
of salem along with you
well drew that's just a snapshot of my
hometown of salem massachusetts i hope
you love it as much as i do i can't wait
for you to visit and i'll see you soon
[Music]